welcome to this video playing alias from
Russia it's a Russian flag at least let
Sam it's a troll d 5 is a solid line
that I picked up from this recent term
Boris avek book on d4 sidelines it seems
to lead to two solid solid play for
black so let's consider is he a
threatening note B 5 mm as is so move
sometimes okay just e6 strongly after as
f three more from Bishop f5 is not
particularly great anyway yeah I didn't
think that this is so terrible Gavin
not great on ethics but I still have
pretty decent development just thinking
about you should be seven here
threatening c4 so Queen B 6 here or not
many moves I could also think about
night h5 trying to to get the bishop
officially five though probably not much
too promising and maybe maybe just this
move I mean a five you can play but I
just drop back threatening c4 again and
it's not clear what all this has
accomplished
interesting
hmm ok let's try to clarify this it's a
bit annoying this night I expect him to
take with the pawn maybe he doesn't need
to ok button but he does i am just
intend to open up composition now try to
miss place as king yeah very quickly
played putting putting the king in the
cell in this diagonal maybe yeah it's no
problem at all but still wonder if I am
obviously he's got c5 yeah i thought the
bishops III would be would be in a trick
but c5 I could take a Jay Quincy five
and Bishop e3 it's not it's not working
for him to me hmm
I don't think I don't think it is
working but everything else is already
very tricky if it's if this is not on c5
is of course the the critical move now
maybe you can take on c7 now that I
located yeah you can take one c7 well
okay then I take the exchange it could
win in various ways instead this is
however interesting I mean it's just
that play but it's still interesting for
white because of this g5 idea Mike
weenis is not well placed probably need
to reroute it
yeah it's difficult to do without the
smooth not sure if it is even working
but if I cannot play it then I'm an even
deeper troll and i will also down on 11
29 so okay
yeah I'm still under pressure so not
easy to play but i guess i can i can
maybe play a 6 it weakens be six but
maybe a six takes Knight eggs and then
95 it's an I don't have I don't have
sufficiently active pieces I need to
need to try to open this up I am I
really fail to guess anymore you that is
playing really not not one couldn't be
one check check p a 95 yeah it's it's
still a bit of pressure but it begins to
be just an exchange so still tricky but
maybe Queen c6 here I'm not sure if I
can take it night c5 and Bishop f5 is
the problem
I could have taken an bishop at five
this would have been stronger okay how
difficult and it probably probably this
is a draw I control c eight so his time
bar doesn't really a check have winning
chances unless I plunder the look the
only way to lose this game unbelievable
okay black resign ok ads it's I need to
know how to break into session i think
i'm just-just winning again here for for
for nothing Luke age 6 this is just a
just a flat-out win here oh isn't it or
is it a draw
I probably a draw he sees god this is
got this activity and I probably cannot
win I probably cannot win but can of
course it's basically impossible to lose
I mean let's say here and then aged 5
yeah that's it should be a draw but look
f2 is so I'm just they're just giving it
away of course and I also made a mistake
here here rookie towards of course
structure and this should win I just
keep the upon my toe came down 120
seconds this is strong lead with winds
at least at least at tempe so this is
important Jim what can you do thanks for
watching